you might have been saying everything is
bigger in texas right even the
sandwiches are so texas melt executive
chef larry getta is here to help us
celebrate national sandwich month las
vegas biggest and boldest grilled
sandwich yes what does that mean how did
you guys get that title
well we uh we make our sandwich big
and stuffed with a lot of meat
and uh
that's why we have a name of texas
smells home of the texas-sized grilled
sandwiches exercise grill sandwiches i
love it okay so let's talk about how you
guys are celebrating for national
sandwich month i hear there's a a weekly
buy one get one deal is that right okay
it's about what's on the menu well texas
miles will feature its favorite sandwich
each week buy one get one free okay okay
the first week we have the dallas which
is
the brisket
and the second week is the
uh midland which i just got a little bit
of different cheese on there right it's
like a philly cheese steak
we're on a texas house okay and then we
have the pool porky which is the houston
okay and we have the corpus christi it's
a half a pound burger
with
smoked brisket on it
smoked 16 to 22 hours oh my gosh yes
okay well and last but certainly not
least is the one where that we're going
to prepare yes that you've got cooking
sizzling we're going to prepare the
texas a big text the big the big text
okay so i'll let you um put the cheese
on okay on the you got okay
yeah yes this is grilled onions okay so
while i put the cheese on we've got
about a minute to build this sandwich
while i put the cheese on explain the
texas toast how that's special because
if you've never had texas toast well the
texas those is basically just a a
pullman sandwich cut thicker okay okay
so and then brown it just a little yes
we're going to melt the cheese a little
bit there you go
yeah that's our chili okay we have to
melt the cheese a little bit the texas
way that's why it's melts
i love it
all right all right there you go now if
you don't have one of those at home
perhaps you could use i don't know a
stove microwave microwave okay and then
this is our smoked brisket oh my look at
this there we go okay we've got a little
little time left here all right throw it
on there and then we have we have the
pulled pork okay
you're going to put that on top you go
and while you finish this off go ahead
keep keep moving and but while you
finish it
so you have to be a rewards member to
actually get the buy one get one right
yes all they have to do is sign up okay
so easy as that yeah and this is uh we
put a little bit of barbecue sauce on it
oh my god all right
and then
and the cheese
on top okay gotta melt it a little bit
oh
and then we put the bacon on and then we
put the bacon to jc we're gonna toss it
j.c so let's let's get the finished
product
okay
and then they put the bacon
all right they go
and then we put the last the last last
there you go i'm not gonna bite this on
air because that's gonna be a mess but
do you see
that
jc i'll send it over to you
all right i'll send it back
this is